the second story which really was the
big story of the week uh the supreme
court heard initial arguments about this
mississippi abortion case which
basically everyone is now saying could
lead potentially to a reversal on roe v
wade we've got some info from the daily
wire on wednesday the supreme court
heard arguments concerning a case
regarding a mississippi abortion law
that could have massive implications for
pro-life laws around the country the
case dobbs versus jackson women's health
organization concerns a 2018 law in
mississippi that bans most abortions
after 15 weeks of pregnancy as the law
stands now roe v wade and the decisions
that came after it hold that states have
to allow a woman to be able to get an
abortion up to the point of viability or
when the baby can survive on its own
outside the womb most states hold this
mark at around 20 to 24 weeks
josh i want to start with you on this
one i saw you at the national
conservatism conference uh the roe v
wade decision generally was one of the
big things being talked about and how
much the courts will get involved in all
of this and will it get to the supreme
court and everything else what do you
make about the arguments that we heard
in the last couple days
yeah so from my vantage point dave this
is kind of like the legal constitutional
issue of all constitutional issues it
has obviously deeply divided america for
for literally the past half century roe
versus wade you know was january of 1973
so we're coming up on the 49th
anniversary of it it was famously um
largely affirmed 19 years later in the
1992 case of planned parenthood versus
casey and the dobbs case out of
mississippi and the underlying statute
is basically a 15-week gestational ban
on abortion with limited exceptions for
after 15 weeks but that's basically the
statute
it does directly put in its crosshairs
both row and casey and this is the best
opportunity that pro-lifers have had for
a modicum of sanity on on the abortion
issue really since the casey case in
1992
and you know i listened to the entirety
of oral argument i mean from kind of a
pro-life and really as a
constitutionalist perspective because
you know as your very well-informed
audience obviously knows roe versus wade
was completely concocted i mean like
they made up a bunch of crap basically
the penumbras the emanations all of this
was just totally philosophized from the
bench in pretty egregious fashion here
and the the very modest claim that kind
of the anti-rose side or at least most
on the anti-rose side make is that the
constitution doesn't speak to this
matter and that is properly an issue for
the for the 50 state legislatures so
some of us actually do go a little
further than that but the kind of
neutral middle ground position which is
on the mainstream i would say
constitutionalist perspective is that
the constitution just allows this issue
to go to the states and i i personally
was actually i listened to the entirety
of oral argument on wednesday i was
quite happy with what i heard to be
honest with you i mean even justice
kavanaugh who i think is considered one
of kind of the swing justices on this
case really kind of came out swinging i
mean he seems to have intuited that this
leave it to the states position is the
neutral middle ground position here so
i feel confident predicting that they're
going to find a way to uphold the
mississippi statute the million-dollar
question is will it be some some sort of
like muddled kind of incremental you
know john roberts special or will they
actually go the full way and actually
overturn all of it but i i will say i
have a lot of friends who even some
friends who clerked on the supreme court
who were texting me afterwards they were
they were really happy with what they
heard it probably couldn't have gone a
whole lot better honestly yeah and for
the record i i discussed this with liz a
couple weeks ago i mean i do consider
myself begrudgingly pro-choice really to
about 12 weeks
without getting too far down that road
but i do kind of understand this
position of this is not a
constitutionally guaranteed right so you
should kick it back to the states i
don't love making that argument uh and i
i get the i get it on both sides but i
that makes sense to me janice what's
what's your take on this
listen uh the divided issue right we're
already a united states that is divided
and this one is going to divide us more
uh when you look at somebody like kathy
hokel who is saying
come on down to new york city we're open
for this procedure whoever wants it i
mean that's that's difficult to hear i i
have two children i am catholic i am
pro-life uh what i don't want to see
is this as a substitute uh for birth
control i don't want teenagers to think
oh well you know i can go out and do
this and and i have so many things that
i can go to including this option which
i think is terrible um and i have so
many friends that are craving for babies
in their life they can't have children
for whatever reason and they are dying
to adopt uh you know i think if
education goes towards other options of
having a child and giving it to loving
family members i think that that's
really important and and i wish that we
would we would get to to something like
that where we have more education to
here's something that you can do you can
have a child and give it to a family
that wants one so badly
yeah well said i mean solutions it's
like if there were more non-profits i
know that many of them exist but if
there were more nonprofits that would
help women who say did not want the
child for whatever reason get that child
to to be adopted or fostered or whatever
maybe that helps a little bit liz is
there any middle ground here like this
is just the one because it brings up
philosophical issues and scientific
issues and religious issues all the
existential issues they're all on the
table here we can't agree on basic
things anymore that two plus two equals
four so it's like is there anything we
can get to on this
well listen the american people i mean
if you if you ignore
the elected officials in washington dc
on both sides of the aisle the american
people actually agree on this issue over
80 percent of the american people want
abortion banned in the third trimester
over 60 percent of the american people
this by the way is both conservative and
liberal pro-abortion and pro-life one
abortion ban in the second trimester the
overwhelming majority of people do agree
on abortion they do want restrictions
it's just the very far left as
politicians who ignore that but i i echo
a little bit of what josh said i
listened to the entire argument it was
about two hours worth in front of the
supreme court and i was shocked actually
by how weak the arguments from the
pro-abortion side were their arguments
were essentially twofold they argued
that because it was quote unquote
settled law it's precedent it's been you
know law for what like almost 60 years
um that
it can't hurt yeah it's true which is
ridiculous i mean that's completely
contradictory yeah to our entire legal
history i mean look at something like
plessy versus ferguson that was
overturned by brown versus board of
education that was about racial
segregation so that argument doesn't
hold any water and then their second
argument was um an argument just about
woman a woman's choice a woman's body
yet they didn't mention anything about
the baby's body which is the
the competing legal interest as we all
know here i thought the arguments from
that side were actually very weak i was
very encouraged after hearing this um
after hearing these arguments and it was
very interesting to hear what some of
the justices said some of the swing
justices how robert was roberts was very
interested in the idea of viability
kavanaugh was very interested in the
idea of the supreme court being neutral
on um on the question of abortion these
are very this is going to be very
interesting um to watch very interesting
to see and i know i uh many of your
viewers i'm sure are joining me in
praying for these nine justices after
they've heard this argument we won't
find out until june what their decision
will be
yeah and also i mean i did watch most of
it and i do have to say i thought that
the the pro-life arguments were just
better like it's exactly what you're
saying they they were more thoughtful
where the others were because because
there just simply is no constitutional
right to an abortion i mean bernie
tweeted it out this morning and it's
like no that's not in the constitution
we can talk about roe v wade but like
it's just not there